guys welcome to step number three on how
to read books to learn foreign languages
now then you've chosen your favorite
book now that you found your position
and the time to better get to reading
sessions it's about time to actually
read the book and you have to get the
tools but the best tool to really is
this it's a really simple tool which is
a pencil what you're gonna do with a
pencil well you're going to mark words
because the whole point of reading is
actually expanding your vocabulary and
actually expanding your world now what
you can do in order to mark words in a
foreign language is simply to put these
words in parentheses I hope you can see
this so that you can put the words that
you don't know in parentheses and then
you can create actually a link or an
arrow at the bottom of the line this is
important where then you will actually
write the meaning of the word in the
foreign language now the cool thing
about this is that you don't need to
stop and look for every single word
every time that you find a word that you
don't know but you can do it at the end
of the session so make sure that you
read all this you read here twenty year
twenty pages or whatever and at the end
of the session you can actually you look
them up on an online vocabulary which is
going to be very fast the reason why
it's because reading is wonderful and
you don't want to disrupt the pleasure
of reading so at the end of every
session you do that so to recap you can
get pencil you can mark words in
parenthesis you can create a link at the
border of the page far from the word and
then I'll tell you why and then you can
add the meaning of the of the words in
your mother tongue thanks for watching
and see you the next episode